clearly um the situation has moved on
but but we have not concluded matters
yet
uh andrew carries a
geographical location title the duke of
york and people in my city 88 of them
have said that they want that shootdown
to be removed and investigating this
this isn't a simple matter where the
queen could remove certain titles from
her son she couldn't remove the title of
duke that has to be through a
parliamentary process whether parliament
bestows more powers on her majesty to
take that decision or whether parliament
itself comes to a conclusion so this is
a issue which needs an anomaly you could
say in law that needs to be addressed
what do you think this means
for the monarchy as a whole
well clearly um this has been a massive
issue
the queen to take such action does show
that these issues are not just about
what's happening within the monarchy but
what's happening across society we know
that violence against women and girls is
at an all-time high and they're the
issues that we really need to get into
to understand what's happening across
our culture our society and to ensure
there is mechanisms not to uphold this
behavior but to address it we know at
the same time the conviction rate on
rape at 1.3
that means that society and our
institutions are failing women at this
time and we need to ensure that we've
got measures in place that's why
labour's appointed a specific minister
to address these issues because we
believe it is so important now to ensure
that our whole society
pivots to protect the rights of women
and girls
should we know how much
the prince the duke of york should say
has had to pay out to
his victim let's call
her well let's say right across this
very um sad situation there has been a
lack of transparency and i mean whether
you know
we're talking about a particular amount
clearly the public wants to know where
that money is coming from is it indeed
coming from the taxpayer ultimately um
or um you know where who is paying for
this but ultimately what we want to see
is real measures being put in place to
first of all acknowledge the level of
harassment and violence that women
experience and then to put those
measures in place to keep women on safe
safe whether it's online whether it's in
the community whether it's at work at
school tragically
at college there is so much that needs
to be done that's why as york is a human
rights city the only human rights city
in england we are taking this spatter
really seriously and somebody who
carries the title of duke they have that
ambassadorial role and um we want our
city to be about standing up for the
rights of women not uh about payoffs for
what did or didn't occur in the past and
therefore we believe that that
disconnection is really important for
our city
great to talk to you thanks for taking
the time to join us this morning thank
you